c'est la fin idéale
j'ai un contrat son journal pour les
nouvelles j'espère qu'elles seront sous
sa super frias grande porte à la fnac et
benzema son coup si les petits
commérages très longtemps le petit écho
de la forêt
[Musique]
il y à toutes les informations à chaque
nouvelle édition on n'a jamais de
déception ça vous le découvrirez dans le
décor de l'offre
[Musique]
rod tiens tiens
boris le loup souffre de sa mauvaise
réputation
or il faut dire que les loups ne sont
pas très aimé on dit tant de choses
terribles sur leur compte mais oui cher
téléphone et on dit que les louanges oms
il est temps qu ils gardent bon et les
renards et même les castors et surtout
les cigognes
mais vous croyez n'importe quoi tu es
bien suivi vous avez donc oublier ce qui
est arrivé au petit chaperon rouge une
seule allée comme et 10 ans et je vais
vous le prouver tiens voilà ce que nous
allons faire et c'est ainsi que déguisé
en petit chaperon rouge
mademoiselle de la cigogne partie dans
la forêt jour et échapper donne rouge
bonbon
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur luis qui vous allez
comme ça tout seul ne saurait c'est ma
mère-grand lui porter cette galette est
enfin vous connaissez l'histoire que
l'histoire est bien en général
s'il faut croire ce qu'on raconte les
loups mme white au sens qu'ils trient le
quart d'heure plus tard à la paix ou de
la merco toc toc toc qu'il a lieu pu
tuer l'homme loup rouge tient la
cheville est et le beau et la bobinette
cherra au jour le club tombe au japon
aux moines au portugal et et puis tu pas
de but merci pas et là sur la table
moi vouloir avoir un nouveau mode même
si vous mangez des baisers parce que moi
adoré mes regrets
il faut pas m'embrasser bon
s'il faut me dévorer aux boules quoi
mais parce que c'est comme ça c'est
écrit un livre moi pour savoir lire
[Musique]
fifi raconté à boris l'histoire du petit
chaperon rouge
et quand notre ami la cigogne frappa à
la porte temps de pâques qui améliore le
petit chaperon rouge
alors toi trait aux bonnes moeurs grand
que vous avez de grands bras c'est pour
mieux embrasser vous enfin moi aux
migrants que vous avez de grandes dents
c'est pour mieux manger vous enfin à moi
ça mais je vous prends sur le fait
méchant loup jeu mais ça ne se passera
pas comme ça venez tous venez voir boris
et amants on se savait qu'on était sûr
il a mangé ma grand mère et enfin je
veux dire fille
c'est affreux boris comment as tu pu
moeurs et fifi nous ne voulons plus tu
vas tu n'es plus dignes de notre ami tu
dois quitter notre forêt et ne plus
jamais revenir jamais je n'aurais pas dû
manger notre mère grand mais je ne suis
pas votre mère gras mais que fait la
fille si tu devrais les dragues à
l'estomac méchant loup boris jeu somme
que moi à voile il va toujours demeurer
mais s'occupe à qui veux tu commençais
mon chèr boris et moi vouloir d'abord
officié galette à suc petit pot de
beurre mois aux lois insulaire partager
avec vous parce que moi vous aimez bien
tous mais moi même mot merci merci merci
alors à table parce que nous tout savoir
et faim de loup et à partir de ce jour
personne dans notre forêt ne que jamais
plus nous raconte
à bientôt je vous donne rendez vous pour
une nouvelle édition
une petite école de la forêt